the coronavirus has forced millions of
people into quarantine and
self-isolation that means millions of
people are working from home some for
the first time we take a look at how
people cope with working from home and
we ask an expert how the crisis might
change how we work for good
I'm sumiso Muskaan de thank you for
joining us people all over the world are
working from home that includes many of
my colleagues here at DW our reporter
Keo Duga sent us a report from her
apartment in Berlin where she set up her
temporary office and she has some tips
on how to make it work actually no one
sees you today take a shower put some
actual clothes on
[Music]
this may sound super obvious but I
haven't gotten my Microsoft teams to
work the entire day learn from my
mistakes make sure everything works
before you have to say a term I know
it's super tempting but set up the
separate clean quiet workspace away from
distraction I know it's easy for me to
say because I don't have kids
my only distraction is my favorite TV
series and the fridge and the laundry
and the dishes and the books you get my
point yes that means you might have to
look presentable but talking
face-to-face is the best way to feel
less alone and happy hour can be virtual
to sleep while you usually be commuting
cook yourself in lunch we should make
the most of it
let's speak now to Norbert to grow now
he's a researcher from the University of
Potsdam studying how people work from
home Norbert thank you for joining us
first of all what do you think of those
tips you know don't work from bed stay
in touch on videoconference you have
anything to add there huge disadvantage
because all travel times are now gone
and immediately be replaced by another
video conference rest and another call
they saw the word density is that's a
fine thought on is much higher than a
typical office work where you have to
walk from one meeting room to another or
where you
walk to the cafeteria or have a break at
the water cooler or the coffee machine
that's all no longer possible alright so
you might have more time a clocked in
you're saying I mean looking at the fact
that millions of people are now in their
home offices essentially what if you
found I mean how does this change the
way we work are we more productive are
we less productive at home well in some
cases because now we can exactly see
what the other colleague is talking
about because we have the PowerPoint
slides crystal-clear or the keynotes
crystal clear on the screen and not
eight meters away in a darkened room and
that's an advantage but on the other
hand what we are focusing on in our
research is that creative and knowledge
intensive processes in businesses they
need the nearness of other people they
can't work in the same manner or online
and in digital meeting rooms and
therefore we are missing something so we
- today we had with my researchers a
virtual lunch break where everybody said
in front of his camera and ate something
and drank something but that's not the
same you cannot achieve the knowledge
transfer between video screens you need
the nearness of persons and in some of
the knowledge intensive processes we
have 75% of knowledge transfer by
socialization by personal meeting
between persons in orbit you know when
all of this is over how do you think
this will fundamentally change the way
that we work well more people stay with
working from home permanently I don't
think so I think some tasks can be done
remotely and some other tasks will need
the personal meeting and it will be
resumed in full when we are able to
travel again I think that won't change a
lot
oh yeah okay we'll have to leave it
there Norbert Grinnell from the
University of Potsdam thank you so much
for joining us and we will be following
this story closely at DW our social
media editors we'll be reporting weekly
and we want to know how you are coping
with working from home we're all so new
to this crazy mind-boggling situation
this virus is not influenza we are in
unchartered territory our life as we
know it is changing dramatically
but we're all in this together in this
new series we want to find out how to
handle our new lives in times of the
corona pandemic thankfully with the help
of leading experts it seems like it's
been a very popular study how do we say
mentally and physically healthy how do
we handle our family and our partners
without driving each other completely
insane first up how to deal with cabin
fever how are you dealing with being
cooped up let me know leave a comment
and I'd love to profit from your
experiences for our upcoming episode
well we asked you to send us some of
your questions on the kovat 19 pandemic
and many of you did get in touch our
science correspondent Dirk Williams has
some answers take a look
where did saw scoff - come from to the
best of our knowledge the first cases of
kovat 19 appeared in the Chinese city of
Wuhan back in December of 2019 they were
closely associated with a wildlife
market they are now coronaviruses can
jump from animals to humans and we think
that that's what happened here the SARS
virus did the same back in 2002 and 2003
it was traced back to bats the civet
sold in wildlife markets we don't yet
know what animals might have acted as
intermediaries here but we have seen
very similar coronaviruses in bats and
we think that they're the ultimate
reservoir in the wild
how does it spread kovat 19 is a pretty
infectious respiratory disease that's
spread by droplets of saliva or
discharge from the nose of someone when
they cough or sneeze that's why it's
important to stay at least a metre away
and preferably farther from anyone who's
coughing or sneezing it doesn't stay
airborne for very long we don't think
but it can remain infectious after
landing on surfaces which is why you
also need to pay attention to how often
you wash your hands and you should try
not to touch your face as much as
possible how do I know if I'm infected
the only way to know for sure if you
have kovat 19:00 is to take a test
because many of the symptoms are similar
to those people experience when they
have other respiratory ailments like the
flu in kovat 19 the primary symptoms
that people have reported our fever dry
cough and fatigue and then to a lesser
extent things like aches congestion a
sore throat or diarrhea some people who
catch the disease don't have any
symptoms at all they're asymptomatic
around 4 & 5 people who get it will
recover from the disease without any
special treatment or having to go to the
hospital what can I do if I'm infected
because this virus is a novel one in
humans no one has any immunity the first
time they catch it even if someone
doesn't show any symptoms they still
grow infected and can infect others we
don't yet have any specific vaccines to
prevent kovat 19 and we don't have any
medications to treat it so at this point
if you are infected
there's no way to interrupt the course
of the disease the best thing to do if
you're infected is to talk with your
local medical authorities and follow
their advice if you aren't in a
high-risk group for the disease the
chances are very good you'll return to
full health within a couple of weeks
if I've had it once can I catch it again
in the future because this is a new
virus we still don't know much about how
the immune system will react to
subsequent infections with kovat 19
doctors assume that catching it will
give you some kind of immunity but a big
question is exactly how long that
immunity will last our immunity levels
to related coronaviruses like some that
caused common colds are not permanent
and we don't really know why the
question of immunity is a question that
really only time will answer a news team
at the Austrian public broadcaster ORF
will go into voluntary isolation to
breath prevent any of them from becoming
infected now they'll be isolated on-site
in Vienna they've all tested negative
for the virus and no one will be allowed
in the door will be guarded and food
will be delivered these 180 employees
will guarantee that new services
continue to run uninterrupted ORF is not
the only Austrian company to seal off
key teams of staff last week around 50
healthy employees from the main energy
company were isolated within certain
power stations to make sure that the
electricity supply would not be affected
thank you for joining our kovat 19
special here on DW as always you can get
the latest on our website DW calm for
all of us here in Berlin thank you for
watching
you